here's the US total fertility rate uh
derived from World Bank data uh you see
a steep uh decline from
1960 to 1980 and then a slower decline
from 1980 to present and then this is
the world fertility rate uh at 2.4
according to the United Nations and
projected to continue downwards so I
guess my question taking all that into
account
is like how is a shrinking
population necessarily a terrible thing
I mean if if we have lifespans
increasing more perhaps more importantly
Health spans increasing and then
technology continuing to create more
goods and
services presumably bringing things down
and filling some of those gaps where the
you know if the workforce is shrinking
you know can automation come in and play
a role and like how much how much
different I guess would the world look
whether we have 10 billion in the in the
year 20 2100 or six billion um is that a
is it a terrible change in quality of
life for the average American or the
average global
citizen one way to think about it is
this when you retire and so let's look
over 150e span even though we probably
don't have to go back that far when you
retire when you're not able to really
make a lot of money later on or when
you're just tired and you want to kind
of rest because you're 70 75 years old
will you have your own children taking
care of you which is a very traditional
model it's kind of on its way out maybe
with six kids I'll be able to have that
who knows will you have sort of a a
assisted living facility where there's
staff there and and they're taking care
of you and they're you know cooking
dinner and and check and there's nurses
to check on you if you're sick or will
you have a little robot with AI zooming
up to take care of you now maybe that
robot will have fewer you know uh
medical mistakes and and less
malpractice than human doctors and and
nurses I don't buy into that techno
Utopia future and I don't think most
people do I think that when we have
fewer people
who are young enough to do the work it
will necessarily have negative cultural
effects it will decrease trusts a lot of
the studies I point out in the book show
how just being around children makes
people more generous with their time
this is non-parents even being around
children makes people more generous with
their time dealing face- Toof face with
humans who we know uh does more to build
social trust does more to improve
people's moods than dealing with uh
faceless bureaucracies with you know
automated processes and that kind of
thing so if if you really just prefer
dealing with artificial intelligence and
robots and computers to dealing with
people then maybe the baby bus is a is
good news but uh no in general I think
for most people it will it will
absolutely be bad news and again when
you look at the uh when you look at the
cultures where this is happening nobody
would tell you that Japan and South
Korea which are far ahead the baby bus
represent happier places than say uh the
the countries you know United States or
northern Europe where we're at least
closer to replacement level or Israel
which I talk a lot about in the book
which has a birth rate over over three
babies per woman of childbearing age the
the the a shrinking society and an aging
Society I think inevitably is a sadder
society and I I lay out lots of
arguments for that in in the book as
well as a techno Ian Catholic I just
want to make it very clear that I want
to have as many children as possible and
then in my old age I want them to be AI
enhanced uh to be able to help with
medical diagnosis but I I do still want
like my kids to be taken care of me
right like surely there's a middle
ground for those techno utopian
Catholics out there right yeah and I'm
I'm
a yeah and you know I'm I'm a father of
three uh so you know I I I love being
around kids um Liz has a a baby and I'm
uh hopefully more on the way uh in not
too distant future uh we're we're both
amateurs uh in relation to your your
brood of six um but you know at the bot
the bottom the bottom line for me is I I
as a Libertarian I don't really care how
many children any individual chooses to
have um what I do care about is are
people unable to have the number of
children that they want to have and so
one of the stats that you cite uh
regularly in your book um that was
concerning to me was this gap between
the number of children that people say
they want to have and the number they
end up having um this is just one
example of the the polling on this
question gallet polling over the
years showing 48% of people want two
children uh this is Americans uh 25% say
three 133% say four or more
uh so you know a large majority want at
least two kids I think you put the
number somewhere between two and three
is the average like 2.4 2.5 something
like
that the mem comes out to be 2.7 but on
that on that chart one of the most
important things is it's 5% that say
they want one or none that's that's
below what I call the the brown cow line
of polling some of you guys might
remember a poll that came out about 10
years years ago that for some reason
asked people where does chocolate milk
come from and one of the answers was it
comes from cows like regular milk but
those are brown cows and that's why it's
chocolate that was 7% 7% is a negligible
number in any poll you had 5% of
African-Americans at one point say that
the uh the Emancipation Proclamation was
a mistake so these are people who like
misheard the question or trolling the
pster and that's the level of people who
say they want Z or one we and I think
they are over represented I think all of
those 5% of the people who who meant to
answer the question that way I think
they're all columnists at the Washington
Post right now because you would assume
that there's a massive childree by
choice or I just want to have one kid by
reading the main media but that's the
most shocking thing about that yet
people are ending up increasingly with
zero or one children um and so and I
think it's it's sad that the number of
people who say say they want less than
four is falling but again we can bracket
that question uh what people want what
people choose yeah as commentators we we
try to nudge people one way or another
but from a perspective of cultural or
policy failures if people want two and
three kids yet they're getting between
one and two and a record number are
getting zero then that shows us that
something is wrong now I'm based in
Washington and so yeah sorry go on I I
just want to know like how much can we
infer from that uh or you know what can
we infer from that in terms of changing
expectations like once you have one kid
or two kids and you start to realize
okay maybe this was more timec consuming
than I expected and I'm gonna like dial
back my expectations a little bit or my
desires change uh once I started having
kids um you know how how much do we know
about that changing
psychology the most of what I've seen uh
that the biggest thing that has changed
is the optimism that and the desire to
have multiple kids and keep working
full-time in your current job outside of
the home that's where after baby number
one the uh the expectations get dialed
down and some people will say okay you
know what I can only have one kid
because I can't afford two daycares or
something but in fact a larger portion
say you know what I just don't value
work as much as I did before I had the
first kid so there's definitely a
recalibration of expectations but it's
mostly how much can you straddle a
full-time job and being a parent and uh
I another thing to so again for me this
reflects that there's something wrong if
people want this thing and then decide
that it's Out Of Reach so the way I I
phrase it is what is the ideal family
size well we often fall short of our
ideals so then we have intentions that
are less than our ideals on anything
right I have an ideal house I'm house
shopping I'm not going to get that what
what do I expect or intend that's always
going to fall short of your ideals but
then what people Millennials especially
are attaining is far less than even what
they intend or expect so their
intentions are are a lot lower than
their ideals and what they get is a lot
less than their intentions or
expectations to me that reflects a real
cultural problem hey thanks for watching
that clip from our new show just asking
questions you can watch another clip
here or the full episode here new
episodes drop every week so subscribe to
reent TV's YouTube channel to get
notified when that happens or to the
just asking questions podcast on Apple
Spotify or any other podcast catcher see
you next week